hey guys my name's Jess it is a
wednesday and here's all the important
things that are going down in video
games also the funniest thing i saw on a
reddit this morning when i was supposed
to be writing my script so be sure to
subscribe for more of that to read it
obviously not to gain foot as if
summoned by an unknown force a
Ghostbusters PlayStation VR game has
suddenly appeared on the PlayStation
Store ghostbusters now hiring is an
episodic series and you can play the
first entry called firehouse today Jake
sim senior vice president of VR at Sony
Pictures told io9 said the plan is to
quote put out chapter one see if people
like it and see what they want then we
can add chapter two and keep going your
ghost guide in the game is also voiced
by Remy from ratatouille himself Patton
Oswalt if you're interested in busting
some ghosts you can grab Ghostbusters
now hiring they are on the u.s.
PlayStation Store for seven bucks it's
currently not available on the UK or
Australian stores but we'll be sure to
let you know as soon as it it while
we're on the subject of ghosts and Ghost
Recon wildlands is set to be updated
very soon the second touch for Ubisoft
latest open-world action game is out
right now on PC and will arrive on
consoles tomorrow one of the biggest and
if you ask me most welcome changes is
the ability to turn off radios by
default you'll also be able to choose
the type of vehicle that spawns when you
use the drop vehicle skill as always
this patch addresses a bunch of other
issues including progression fixes UI
tweaks carp and connectivity fixes as
well as performance improvements the
patch weighs in at three gigabytes on
console and five gigabytes on PC it
seems the patches are out in for fourth
today as a Mass Effect Andromeda update
has arrived that plans to address a
bunch of single and multiplayer issues
Bioware has also suggested that
improvements might be on the way for the
game's facial animations that sometimes
look like this rotten scoundrel
hey now the drink not you yeah anyway
patch 1.04 fixes some game-breaking bugs
and audio issues as well as delivering
improvements too many cinematics
conversations and other character
interactions of course that might not
refer to those controversial facial
animations when else on Twitter if we
can expect said animations to be
addressed lead designer ian fraser
applied we're looking at patching lots
of issues and want to strongly support
the game looking forward i can't say
more just yet he added the fire where is
also looking into ways to make
Andromeda's character creative better
which if any of you have also spent
dozens of minutes trying to make a not
ugly Ryder you probably understand you
can check out the full list of patch
notes in our story on Gabe slides that
is everything I've got for you today do
stop by games but for all the latest
news and features hit that subscribe
button if you liked today's video and
I'll see you again tomorrow